[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys
careful boys and we got rick back great
always fun
we just moved you didn't lose a sick
place he says you could see the ocean in
the morning do you live in an la house
you can see the ocean long beach oh
there you go that's better
oh downtown long beach [ __ ] rick made
it dude it's over
an apartment okay nice nice that's great
man congrats do you ever go to the ocean
or just stare at it um
crazy [ __ ] before we live there we was
at the the beach that we see all the
time we have not gone once
since we moved in really we got it yeah
yeah because just i don't know it's
right there is it enough now
so there you go
isn't it calming when you wake up and
you just see ocean it's pretty dope i
see oceans i see all of our
shipments that aren't getting delivered
just sitting there
there's hella ships out there right now
huh all the shipping containers you see
the boats just [ __ ] lined up it's
there why aren't they getting delivered
what's going on they're not looking
there's something for something i don't
know but
if you go to the ports they're [ __ ]
field so yeah but every shortage huh
wonder why it's crazy
i feel the crypto going crazy yeah
probably everyone's doing the
cryptocurrency
yeah they're just on the boats just on
the good though
they're all [ __ ] on their boss's
desk because they made so much
nobody wants to work man that's
fantastic just buying luke all day
[Laughter]
uh dude i noticed that uh because i'm a
beach guy i love the beach and [ __ ] but
yeah your tan is looking real good thank
you very much
california beaches suck dick ass they do
am i crazy yeah they do compared to
where though oh well everywhere else
i've been that's true everywhere else
you know
beach i have been redundant
it's nice it's nice i would say like
from the south bay south the beaches get
really nice yeah san diego man there's
some areas in san diego where it's like
it looks like hawaii but but but it
doesn't the water looks like [ __ ]
that's true you just gotta go to some
certain places yeah i'm talking about
tropical i mean yeah there's no place in
california where you're knee-high water
and you see a neon fish exactly and it's
warm ever or you even see your own neon
fish
you see dark gray fish though that's
okay
we should introduce neon fish yeah yeah
go get some and bring
a diaper all you do is put it in put the
bag in the ocean for a little while and
let it sit there and then it gets used
to it and then you can let the neon
like a nemo yeah yeah and then let the
bag go with the v8
hopefully you can get the bag back did
they just spill like a hundred and like
twenty thousand gallons and like that's
what makes the fish neon exactly oh
that's elsa
or something that area and it was like
uh of oil just a gang of oil that they
just keep releasing in the [ __ ] water
like no it's elsagando it was like a oil
pipe that bursted underneath yeah it was
an oil pipe but there was a new one in
like orange county here oh maybe it's
the same one it was human waste wasn't
the idea human waste was a santa monica
area
the other one was oil
like like a sewer plant like a sewer
processing plant they're [ __ ] pipes
bursting oh that's right because el
segundo has a processing oh yeah maybe
it was the dookie and the elsa gundog
and just went into the ocean hella yeah
yeah and all they do is they just a
shitty day for the fish dude did you
guys see the jacksonville jaguars game
where the there's a pipe that burst and
a bunch of human [ __ ] was falling out no
what no way dude man
that's great and it's better because
this jags fans
[Laughter]
one of the worst teams in the [ __ ]
league
they've always been bad too extra duped
on yeah
but did this happen recently yeah it was
really recently i could be wrong on the
team but i just want to say jack yeah
i could be wrong on all of it
what's your guys favorite beach that you
guys been to oh man like in the world
in the whole world
probably all these beaches are too
[ __ ] nuts bro yeah hawaii any of them
too huh any of them even the one in
holland uh waikiki area that's super
touristy even those are sick too bahamas
bro we've never been in bahamas you
gotta go to the bahamas if you want a
sick beach [ __ ] water looks fake it
looks like they bleached it or some [ __ ]
yeah
they feel the pictures it does i heard
tulum and all that is really nice too
but when i went it looked like chocolate
milk and then there was mountains of
seaweed it looked like the great wall of
seaweed you can't even go in the water
it was nasty when i went to tell them
the water was blue but they didn't have
the wildlife like hawaii did yeah but
there's no fish i mean not like a it's
more like california where you might see
one fish oh but like in hawaii you walk
in the water and it's just [ __ ] i
think because of the coral or whatever
but there's fish everywhere and i was
snorkeling last week man i think i saw
like 500 like a school of 500 fish
actually was crazy my [ __ ] nephew
swam in it like he was running through a
flock of pigeons and [ __ ] and made him
scatter did you see any turtles oh yeah
there was one sleeping under a big-ass
rock you saw a sleeping turtle under a
rock yeah we did too man it was awesome
good ass goggles down there
how does he even know he's sleeping it's
incredible he was just like this he was
knocking on the shelf he had like one
air bubble that was like going in and
out of his nose he was sleeping like
that actually
have you guys been to palawan what's
that oh you just made that up dude no no
no oh philippines is sick i've never
been like illest snorkeling i've ever
been to in my life just the pictures are
crazy um yeah like literally
i don't know if it's just the coral
reefs haven't got [ __ ] up yet by
people or what but it's like it's like
for real finding nemo like i've been
snorkeling in hawaii in a few places too
but hawaii's like half of what the
philippines is
wow that's crazy because like you know
how like people in midwest or whatever
they go to um like the west coast
they're like oh my god it's a beach or
like people from new york they go to
like florida and they're like i love the
beach right but then californians go to
hawaii or other tropical places to go to
the beach not like in california yeah
because we're used to it
yeah i know one's here at least i've
been to a really nice dog beach in perth
i remember the name of it
and only a couple of gnats bit me so
rosie's is nice it's nice
there's a great dog what's that one
that's one of long beaches oh okay that
was awesome
the honeymoon beach one's better i think
oh there's one in huntington beach yeah
it's huge way better i've never been
over that one i didn't know i don't like
driving to huntington it's far far yeah
i'm out dude but it's worth it yeah it
is this says snorkeling at corn port
philippines 3.8 stars sorry
you're full of [ __ ]
man hey this is this is the sister beach
so jacksonville jaguar oh dude two stars
i did i did look for a while for this
[ __ ]
no it's apparently really nice it's
poland you gotta take like three flights
to get there one of those kind of things
where you gotta like get and fly into
the country and then you gotta go to
like this other port and they gotta take
you by a little boat to this like other
little island area because there's a ton
of little islands right there
philippines
i saw these like filipino like
uh divers like they die for like [ __ ]
oyster shells or whatever right they
live this village that they live on it's
on the water oh yeah they live on sticks
on the water i was like what the [ __ ]
right and then these guys they would go
in
and then they timed how long they could
hold their breath these guys were in
there for like five minutes no goggles
nothing just walking in the bottom of
the water just collecting [ __ ]
five minutes dude i'm like damn dude
did you see the the clip of the guy one
of the dudes that was like like the
indigenous that area he was gonna try to
set the uh world record for like the
deepest dive he almost passes out yeah
he comes out of the water and then he's
like about to [ __ ] like pass out and
i thought there was like a more
professional way to wake people up but
they just all took turns slapping him
[Laughter]
that's a medical way
dude that's crazy
and he woke up
he's indigenous he's still named j.r
that's crazy you gotta like map out
your 50 you know like half of your
breath is gonna go here because you
can't go you're 100 because you're dead
and they got that pipe too right that
they kind of like follow all the way
down yeah shit's great and they're going
like 200 feet deep and [ __ ] look at this
[ __ ] beach dude
yeah that beaches hey get that
why did you get a girl get her to get
out of the way trying to get her out of
the way yeah that looks like a manhattan
beach you gotta get the idea though
oh yeah yeah that's a clear beach where
is that geographically speaking the
bahamas that's right that looks like
hawaii too it's crazy it's got water
you know close enough look at this [ __ ]
though
[ __ ] that's the philippines right
there
wow
dude that looks like you could fall into
the abyss in the middle yeah that is the
event for sure right i saw this video of
a in the philippines it's an island
um and it's surrounded by water right
but then inside it's like a crater and
that's salt water too so it's an island
with another like what are those called
um it's like a donut of land like a
sandbar it's almost like a cinderella
giant stone it's giant turquoise water
look at that [ __ ] that's the bahamas
dude that looks like hawaii too though
it does what are we doing here they diet
here or something i don't know what they
do they die that's crazy now anthony you
go to maui a lot yeah i've been there
not a lot i've been there like twice
okay what beach do you like more i was
just in maui last week oh yeah that's
right would you guys like the beaches in
oahu more or maui
maui maui maui is like better beaches
right but not the city though there's
not so much good food today's video is
brought to you by draftkings
the killer crossovers
the nothing but net jumpers
the tenacious throwdowns
ladies and gentlemen basketball is back
draftkings the leader of fantasy sports
is celebrating the return to the
hardwood by giving new customers a shot
of millions of dollars
in total prizes
playing daily fantasy hoops is easy just
pick your lineup of pro basketball
players stay under the salary cap and
rack up points for three pointers
rebounds assists and more score big and
you can score big cash and with a free
shot at a million dollars of total
prizes it's the perfect time to show off
that basketball iq
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
best of all you can deposit and withdraw
your cash whenever you want download the
draftkings app now and use the code off
the record this week new customers can
get a free shot at a million dollars
worth in total prizes don't forget to
enter the promo code off the record for
a shot at a million dollars in total
prices that's off the record only at
draftking there's a minimum five dollars
deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
for details i i actually like maui
better really yeah what about food wise
no i mean yeah food is
you got to go to wahoo i think i had to
live in hawaii oahu but yeah like to
vacation and visit maui's just like
extra vacation you know what i mean yeah
yeah and then the snorkeling's better
yeah maui has to be next though dude
yeah like i had a snorkeling hands down
the snorkeling's way better waikiki
beach dude food
the beach
the water the rocky sand they got a
cheesecake factory he's got all those
like bombs that be like stealing from
each other on on the beaches though why
is there sound so [ __ ] hard as [ __ ]
dude it sucks
i don't know why yeah did i bring it
there like the waikiki beach technically
no i blame the indigenous people avoid
j.r
[Laughter]
john ryan
[ __ ] john ryan dude filipino jrs do
you know every i bet you every filipino
family has a john ryan john ryan is that
what it stands for or no i i think it
stands for [ __ ] anything with a j and
an r isn't it just spelled j-a-y-a-r
isn't it like j-r oh i've seen that too
i've seen hell of filipinos that have
that oh maybe
i thought it was because it was like
[Laughter]
how many filipinos do you know rick
count them right now rick probably knows
the most filipinos
the filipinos are my family is like
they're all benjamin so i don't know
really yeah i actually think that they
probably have more filipinos around them
than we do yeah are any of them be ours
uh benjamin
b
but they all call each other nicknames
i've talked about this before but they
yeah they call each other like uncle
benny and uncle jiggy and uncle uncle
jiggy hell yeah
yeah
uncle abuse i think you're the third
person that knows the most filipinos
okay
hey be more proud of it
you didn't seem that excited
to get third ranked in the group of six
you're like i know i'm hard
i'm perfectly mediocre
well the best thing is that the white
people are slowly taking over their
whole family
so like i said they're slowly marrying a
lot of white people more what more and
more white people so it's like the
weirdest [ __ ] thing
hey do you do you talk [ __ ] to the other
white people like i'm the prime white
guy yeah i was i'm the og optimus braun
you're the great white guy you guys are
living up to it are you the only white
guy on that side or no no no no it's i'm
telling you it's like crazy it's like
it's more and more because the grandma
wanted them all to marry filipino dudes
and then they keep on bringing more
white dudes home because it's all they
saw you and was like
yeah that's you know what i'm saying
it's not for example it's no way but
it's all important
you're nikki's dad married a white
exactly right so exactly so even the
guys are married like i think since the
start it's like it's like slowly
happening so it's like a big family joke
that like oh boy another whitey's here
and all [ __ ]
how many asians are in your wife's side
of the family or married i'm the only
asian i'm the only chinos they say me
too yeah
is it weird or not nah it's great they
call you chino no they don't as well
that'd be cool though
wow i feel accepted i got a nickname
their family's great dude i love their
family that's cool
but i wish they wouldn't call me chinos
online
and they're like um
slightly drunk
then it's not towards me
but it's just like over your left
shoulder it's you know you know
like like like let's say um
like like let's say i don't know maybe
10 years ago like let's say we used to
say [ __ ] her a lot that [ __ ] this
[ __ ] that [ __ ] or whatever right and
then so [ __ ] just means dude [ __ ]
yeah and then so when someone comes in
like oh can you tell the [ __ ] i'm like
oh my bad that's that's that's my
friend's dad don't call him [ __ ] so
that's what you're just they're just so
used to saying like this yeah so when
he's referring to our asian guy they're
so saying chinito or china or whatever
yeah because it just means aging so
they're just saying they're just having
a good time i don't know i mean bar like
a bar you want a beer or two rather than
like at least they got it right for you
guys yeah you guys are actual chinese
yeah
i mean my bad my bad just means chinese
dude chinese guy and then or like cute
china they they sing a song every time i
come to the house though and it goes
chino chino japones
i've always seen that they sing it to me
they sing it to me
every time i mean chinese chinese
japanese you have entrance music eat
[ __ ] you can't
family goes nuts dude sick they go crazy
chino chino hop on a school manchaka no
maybe they say it all the time i go in
the house real sick
it's a real show dude
fireworks dude it's nuts it's nuts it's
a good time wow yeah it's expensive
it's fireworks
thanksgiving christmas that's it yeah
yeah that's about it fire marshall
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's all safe everything you have to
have an outfit for it too everything's
regulated yeah yeah yeah what is it like
a big straw hat and a [ __ ] glittery
chinese outfit it's just shawn michaels
that's what i want to do are we doing
halloween this year what's going on with
halloween because like you know as a
nation yeah yeah yeah because they
cancelled it
well last year
huge question needs to be answered for
everybody in america
as a nation i think uh
wasn't it trick-or-treating like
canceled last year yeah pretty much
what's in l.a
our neighborhood still did a small one
though they're just like they got so we
have like a little like a app or
whatever
and then they all they all like arrest
bart dude they all chatted and they're
like who's comfortable with it who who's
doing it you have an app for your
neighborhood no it's like you can
everyone has one you can like uh the
neighborhood like i don't group me or uh
or oh like a whatsapp and then everyone
gets together on chat oh who said an app
like you built a app
[Music]
he's lying because they're not supposed
to know but there is an app yes they
have actual fun
it's like the neighborhood the
neighborhood app or some [ __ ] people
report crimes and [ __ ] yeah it's almost
better than social media you talk about
ring camera [ __ ] that it's like that but
like that was the neighborhood
so it's like oh i lost a dog see a
torrent
no like like yeah like it could be
smaller and they could be like oh i lost
a dog there's a weird guy wandering
outside my house a lot of the stuff you
see on the ring camera yeah i have that
fascinating that's cool because it's
kind of like bringing community back you
know like we could be paranoid together
dude the best thing is like that was
gunshots i'm like it was not gunshots
it's never it's never gunshots it's
always fireworks fireworks it's fire
easy you should be like no that's not
hold on and then you go
that was gunshot
a shoddy by the way
the only problem is the people are the
loudest are the the dudes that want to
act hard even though they're like a
[ __ ] 50 year old man
and then a ton of cairns like there's
this literally that this lady in my old
neighborhood she was just saying there's
not enough speed bumps in this
neighborhood we got to get way more
because the kids are in danger and every
day she just wants to talk about [ __ ]
10 debuffs like you're just driving like
this speed bumps going into the park
past the park and then on the other side
we need more speed bumps and the every
day is just about speed bumps god damn
it you should just take the whole street
with speed bumps until she [ __ ]
and kids don't play outside anymore hell
no how often do you where they may be in
vegas bro they're inside playing pirate
game dude
pirate game they're playing [ __ ] xbox
live
parks they're watching they're making
tick tocks in their room like they're
not out in the streets
what age are we talking about nick
did they jump out of a bus
fortnight four or four great that's the
one they're all playing i was like they
jump out of a bus what the hell is
specific they are they do jump out of
here they do they do i was thinking of a
school bus on land though
yeah true my bad
yeah who came up with that like a
rocket bus
right and everyone dives out of the
rocket bus and then they parachute onto
the island yeah whatever great game and
then the guys are like now you're a
[ __ ] idiot dude and it becomes the
biggest thing i know
it's everywhere kids pay kids like take
their parents credit cards and like
charge [ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ] to get
cool items they could look more like
batman in the game
there's nothing else for them that's it
yeah that's their whole business model
hey do you think today i look more like
batman than yesterday
30 more dollars i looked even more like
batman tomorrow they're so expensive
it's so expensive
because the game is free to play but
what they're banking on is these kids
taking parents credit cards
yeah and getting all the add-ons it's a
business model dude
right pay to play dude work batman or my
[ __ ] senile ass grandma she buys gems
and this wizard of oz app that she plays
and i don't think she knows what [ __ ]
she's doing but she's draining her
entire retirement [ __ ] just on the gems
and [ __ ]
but those gems are important for that
like physical gems nah dude like in-game
app gems
but it rewards you with this little like
[ __ ] you went to the casino this guy
with that shiny sound yeah but she loves
it dude this guy plays no games he
doesn't even get the premise of it i
barely play games i don't even have a
console no movies no games
he watches his [ __ ] kid that's what
he does i watched spider-man you didn't
watch spider-man you watched taika watch
flashlight
exactly
this guy turned down tickets for the
tyson fury deontay wilder fight to watch
his kid watch us why you got to wrap me
up like that
we talked about her writing good dad and
[ __ ] yeah
get the [ __ ] out of
dad you're supposed to take a big [ __ ]
on him not to call him a good dad
no i'm saying stop being good
go to the fight stupid
come to the fight stupid spider-man
whatever he wants dude you literally
have watched spider-man this weekend
with him but instead you decided to duck
the [ __ ] greatest fight that
everyone's ever seen the rock said it
was the best fight he's ever seen and
that's the rock i'm gonna probably
re-watch it right rox is the guy who
gets some [ __ ] bubba coming out
during his walkouts and [ __ ] you're
talking about a guy who went to like 17
wrestlemanias dude he says that this was
actually the best fight he ever saw oh
yeah
he fought uh stone cold steve
twice yeah a couple times did tycho
watch spider-man watching stone cold
didn't think so good dad
just pissed
[Music]